a constituent at an AOC town hall
suggests eating babies to curb climate
change well everyone is outraged at the
remark we examine what exactly is wrong
with this modest proposal and whether or
not it's any worse than what we've heard
from Democratic presidential candidates
then Warren finds herself embroiled in a
major sex scandal no I am NOT talking
about Jacob walls accusation that warren
bedded a twenty-something marine I'm not
talking about that I am talking about
Warren's latest lies about sex
discrimination and how they fit in with
a broader pattern of biographical
dishonesty finally we prepare for a
Supreme Court case tomorrow that could
determine the future of sex and gender
identity in the United States and on
that point of sex and gender identity
and all of the social issues the new
york times finally runs openly honest
fictional op eds at least they're honest
all that more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
I am about to give apparently a
controversial opinion so look media
matters
sleeping giants any of the left-wing
operatives who watch this show for my
controversial opinions here it is get
ready I don't think we should eat the
babies okay there I said it and if it
costs me my shows so be it but I don't
think we should eat the babies you're
gonna see a lot of headlines now but
Noel's it wants to destroy the climate
because he won't eat the babies well
we're gonna get into this modest
proposal for eating babies to stop
climate change but first well we still
have them I want to thank our wonderful
sponsors over at NetSuite it is very
important if you are starting a business
if you are growing a business if you are
working for a growing business you need
to know your numbers I've been involved
in a lot of start-up businesses
including this one right here The Daily
wire it is so important the the biggest
problem probably that growing businesses
have I think this is a bigger problem
than any of the others is they they have
this hodgepodge of business systems and
they can't know their numbers that's
where NetSuite comes in very handy
NetSuite by Oracle is the business
management software that handles every
aspect of your business in an easy to
use cloud platform this gives you the
visibility and control that you need to
grow with NetSuite you save time you
save money and you save unneeded
headaches and by the way time is money
again people forget this when they're
starting to business time is money okay
and so what they'll do is they'll have
all these different business systems and
one manages sales one does finance one
does accounting none of them are talking
to each other you can't access them all
and and you'll lose a lot of time and
money don't make that mistake NetSuite
by Oracle you can handle sales finance
accounting orders HR instantly right
from your desktop or phone that is why
NetSuite is the world's number one cloud
business system right now NetSuite is
offering you valuable insights with a
free guide seven key strategies to grow
your profits that is at NetSuite calm
slash Knowles kano wles do me a favor if
you've got some business aspirations
you're working for a growing business
you have a business yourself do me a
favor go right
now cost you nothing NetSuite comm /
Knowles ko wles you will get your free
guide seven key strategies to grow your
profits NetSuite comm / Knowles they
want to eat the babies they want to eat
the babies this was a constituent at an
AOC town hall they were talking about
climate change and she offered her
modest proposal for how to really stop
the impending climate crisis climate
crisis we only have a few months left I
love that you support the Green Deal but
it's not get it you know get it with a
fossil fuel it's not gonna solve the
problem fast enough a Swedish professor
saying that we can eat their dead people
but that's not fast enough so I think
your next campaign slogan has to be this
we got to start eating babies we don't
have enough time there's too much co2
all of you you're you you know you're
pollutant too much co2 we have to start
now please you are so great I'm so happy
that you really support a nuclear deal
but it's not enough you know even if you
would Bob Russia we still have too many
people too much pollution so we have to
get rid of the babies that's a big
problem just stopping babies a sign that
we need to eat the babies under the
spaces please thank you okay so this is
obviously a stunt some people are saying
the woman is a little kooky some people
are saying it's just a political stunt
that opposes aoc the answer is actually
it's both of those things this woman is
a little kooky and this is a stunt and
it is satire and it's very very good
satire the one report that is just a
complete lie from the mainstream media
some people are saying that this woman
is conservative or they're insinuating
that she's conservative she's not she's
a member of a group called the LaRouche
PAC these are followers of Lyndon
LaRouche for those who don't remember
LaRouche is pretty out there
the LaRouche movement though is not a
conservative movement
grew out of the 1960s radical left some
of the things that the the LaRouche
people want are they want to regulate
Wall Street and they want to change our
system of exchange rates so they oppose
free floating exchange rates which began
in the 1970s they support massive
federal infrastructure spending one big
issue for them is they want a Eurasian
landbridge so a land bridge connecting
you know a super-duper highway from from
Europe all the way to Siberia they
support colonization of Mars they
support a different system of tuning for
classical music this is an important
issue for the LaRouche back and they
support certain defense initiatives but
not others for instance they support
laser based defense initiatives but not
anti-ballistic missile systems so not
easy to categorize on the right or the
left it's a little bit of a kooky
political movement Lyndon LaRouche
himself ran for president eight times
the first time was with the US Labor
Party the next seven times were with the
Democratic Party this was as recently as
2004 so anybody who's telling you this
this is a conservative or even
right-wing political group that she's
with is not telling the truth that's it
it's a very good satire because I think
I think now the LaRouche PAC supports
Trump I'm not sure I wouldn't be
surprised if they support Trump I think
they oppose the global warming alarmism
so you know it's not easily categorized
but in so much as this is satire making
fun of global warming alarmism it's
really really good satire what the left
is trying to say is Oh give me a break
this woman's so crazy this isn't even
close to what we think it is it's really
close to what we think the argument that
the woman is making is that babies
expend too much carbon dioxide and they
use too many resources and they're
hurting the public and society because
of climate change so we need to eat the
babies that's the whole satire who is
the satire directed toward the left this
is not just coming from fringe people
this is coming from candidates for
president in a recent CNN Town Hall
talking about climate change
Bernie Sanders the number-two candidate
in the race according to some polls now
he's fallen most polls down to number
three but you're talking about a
top-tier candidate Bernie Sanders was
asked explicitly if we should kill
babies to curb climate change his answer
was immediate and emphatic yes human
population growth has more than doubled
in the past 50 years the planet cannot
sustain this growth I realize this is a
poisonous topic for politicians but it's
crucial to face empowering women and
educating everyone on the need to curb
population growth seems a reasonable
campaign to enact would you be
courageous enough to discuss this issue
and make it a key feature of a plan to
address climate catastrophe well most of
the answers yes and the answer has
everything to do with the fact that
women in the United States of America by
the way have a right to control their
own bodies and they and the Mexico City
agreement which denies American aid to
those organizations around the world
that are that allow women to have
abortions or even get involved in birth
control to me is totally absurd so I
think especially in poor countries
around the world where women do not
necessarily want to have large numbers
of babies and where they can have the
opportunity through birth control to
control the number of kids they have
something I very very strongly support
how is Bernie's argument any different
from the woman's argument the woman said
we should kill and eat babies Bernie
said we should just kill the babies we
should do both of those things because
of climate change what this is based on
is a satire by Jonathan Swift called a
modest proposal specifically it's called
a modest proposal for preventing the
children of poor people from being a
burden to their parents or country and
for the for making them beneficial to
the public and this was the satire by
the Irish writer Jonathan Swift the idea
being that you
got all these poor Irish babies and
they're a burden to the public and
they're it's taking up too many
resources so what we should do is feed
them feed them to rich people and we
should eat the babies Bernie when he
eaten a Bernie is not talking about
eating babies he's just talking about
killing babies but he does say
specifically we need to expand abortion
in poor countries
he says especially poor countries we
don't need to just kill the babies here
in the United States to fight climate
change especially in poor countries with
all those bothersome poor people who are
taking up too many resources they're in
the poor countries most especially we
need to kill the babies now today when
he's talking about poor countries or
third world countries he's talking about
Africa and parts of Asia which brings in
this whole racial aspect to it if he
were writing in the 18th century like
Jonathan Swift we'd be talking about the
Irish babies we need to go in there and
kill these poor babies but it gets even
better because you could say well look
he's just talking about killing them and
the lady at the aoc event was talking
about killing and eating them and for
some reason those are completely
different and it's good to kill the
babies but it would be really bad to
kill and eat the babies and no one's
talking about eating the babies
therefore Michael the analogy is not a
good one except except the left is
talking about eating people to last
month a Swedish scientist was speaking
at a Swedish scientific summit and
suggested that cannibalism is a great
way to fight climate change this guy was
not engaging in satire this guy was dead
serious the Stockholm School of
Economics Professor Magnus soderlund
what a name said that eating human meat
is a great way to help save the human
race if society would simply quote
awaken the idea he's talking about
eating a dead people so he says people
die and we've got all this good meat
that we're just putting underground what
a huge waste of that if we could just
eat that meat then we wouldn't have to
grow so much food and raise cows and
then we could help save the world when
this came out this was referred to as
the Soylent Green New Deal based on the
Charlton Heston movie where
the food is people you remember Soylent
Green sour green is people so you you
have a scientist suggesting that
cannibalism is a good way to fight
climate change you have a Democratic
presidential candidate suggesting that
killing babies is a good way to fight
climate change and then you have a
political satirist at this AOC event
suggesting that eating babies is a good
way to fight climate change that's not a
big stretch and she's not only
channelling very fringe voices she's
channeling mainstream voices number
three sometimes number two depending on
what poll you're looking at in the
Democratic presidential race so if you
say this is so ridiculous let's say that
you're in the center or you're on the
left and you say how ridiculous it is
that this woman is talking about eating
babies ask yourself what's ridiculous
about it
we're already it's already a mainstream
proposal to kill babies to fight climate
change you have a scientist now talking
at a big summit about eating people by
the way if there's no moral order if
there's no if you don't believe in a
transcendent moral order you don't
believe that we're made in the image of
God and you don't believe God exists and
you think we're all just kind of meat
puppets and this is a material world why
is it wrong to eat dead people but by
that logic by the logic of materialism
in atheism I don't really see why it's
that wrong I mean it's obviously wrong
because there is a transcendent moral
order but if there weren't why would it
be wrong to eat dead people that's what
this guy that's what the scientist is
saying now take that logic to its
logical conclusion if you are willing to
go so far into the realm of the absurd
and the disgusting as to say that we
should kill human babies to fight the
weather why is what this political
satirist saying why is that so
outrageous it is outrageous but it is
outrageous and wrong and crazy by the
logic of the left that's
what we're getting into and so when you
look at the arguments they're making
those arguments are going to be
expressed in certain candidates and
we've already looked at Bernie Sanders
one of the top-tier candidates he is
explicitly making that argument how are
the candidates do it how we are looking
not just at flawed arguments as we look
at 2020 we're looking at very flawed
candidates so Bernie Sanders the one who
suggested we kill babies to fight the
weather is the biggest fundraiser in the
Democratic field right now he is the by
far the biggest he raised in the third
quarter twenty five point three million
dollars next up was Liz Warren she had
twenty four point six million dollars
way behind in third place is Joe Biden
at fifteen point two million dollars
what did Trump raise Trump raised 125
million now Trump way outpaced Barack
Obama in his reelection campaign in 2011
in the third quarter Obama raised 70
million Trump is not quite double that
but getting close to double that now you
might say okay all the Democratic
candidates sure they've raised some
money and it's nowhere close to what
Trump raised but they haven't picked a
nominee yet sure but look at the total
money twenty five point three million
for Sanders twenty four point six
million for Warren let's call that an
even 50 million combined and then Joe
Biden behind with a fifteen point two
million so you're looking at 65 million
that's combined for the top candidates
the only real candidates I think at this
point who have a shot at getting the
nomination that's behind Barack Obama's
re-election campaign and it's way behind
Trump that is almost almost half just a
little over half of what what Trump
pulled in in the third quarter so not
looking good for the arguments on the
left or the candidates the good news for
the Democrats is that Bernie Sanders his
health is okay right now it looks like
he's okay
bad news is he had a heart attack last
week he didn't announce that he had a
heart attack his campaign didn't
announce that he had a heart attack the
New York Times got the information from
his doctors and his campaign later
confirmed it this is clearly a
vulnerability for the campaign if it
were not a vulnerability the Sanders
campaign would have come right out and
said
but they did you don't want a
presidential candidate who's having
heart attacks on the campaign trail I'm
very glad that Bernie Sanders is okay
this is bad news for his campaign you
know Dick Cheney had heart attacks even
had heart attacks after he was elected
to be the vice president but he never
had heart attacks just before an
election and he was the vice president
he wasn't the president the United
States people are very wary of this John
McCain had excellent health when he ran
for president in 2008 he lived for what
another ten years after that and people
said I don't know he's a little old and
we don't like this Sarah Palin lady so I
can't vote for McCain Bernie Sanders is
78 years old right now he'll be 79 on
election day 2020 he'll be 83 on
election day 2024 that is a big
vulnerability so I think the public sees
Bernie Sanders is too old same issue for
Joe Biden Joe Biden is floundering his
poll numbers have collapsed he once had
a 25 point lead over Bernie Sanders he
once had a 33 point lead over Elizabeth
Warren now he's tied with Warren he's
all the way down tied with Warren
according to the Real Clear Politics
average this is looking at all the polls
Joe Biden has 26.3% - Liz Warren's 26
percent that is a statistical tie MSN is
now reporting that major Joe Biden
donors met in Philly this past weekend
to discuss the future of the campaign
this being reported in left-wing outlets
according to an economist YouGov poll
Liz Warren is now not just tied with
Biden she's now up four points on Joe
Biden 26 to 24 to 14 a Bernie Sanders
way in the back no wonder Joe Biden's
funders are worried of I would I would
be worried too
because his campaign right now is a very
serious risk of looking like the Jeb
campaign in 2016
Jeb Biden exclamation point and Joe
Biden is the most normal of these
candidates and Joe Biden is supporting
radical proposals taxpayer funding for
abortion that sort of stuff so then
you've got Bernie Sanders he's too old
and he thinks we should kill babies to
appease the weather gods you've got an
end Bernie Sanders had a heart attack on
the camp
doesn't bode well for his 20/20 chances
you got Joe Biden collapsing his poll
numbers gone Liz Warren leading we're
tied in polls and in the river politics
average so it's got to be Warren right
not so fast Liz warns facing another
scandal major scandal rocking her world
not the Jacob Wall sex scandal to catch
you up if you missed that one Jacob wall
who is a a right-wing troll came out and
is suggesting that Liz Warren paid a
young marine in his 20s for sex I got to
tell you I don't buy it
I just don't if Liz Warren has never had
a beer if she's awkward drinking a beer
on camera and she's kind of hugging her
husband in a weird way I just I of all
the scandals you're gonna throw in Liz
Warren I don't think sex with a young
marine is the one that's gonna stick the
sex scandal that she's facing is lying
about sex discrimination she's now
facing a major lie about her biography
so last Wednesday during a town hall in
Nevada Liz Warren said that she once
lost a job because she was pregnant she
said quote by the end of the first year
I was visibly pregnant and the principal
did what principals did in those days
wish me luck ins hire someone else for
the job he discriminated against me on
sex and he fired me because I was
pregnant that's what she's saying
however video surfaced from a 2008
program called conversations with
history which might be a prophetic title
if this video ends Liz Warren's
presidential campaign as she will have
been history in that video she said she
wasn't fired because she was pregnant
she said she was fired because she was
unqualified for the job and she decided
to do something else and she was
pregnant and she decided to raise her
kids here is Liz Warren in 2008 my first
year post graduation I worked it was in
a public school system but I worked with
the children with disabilities and I did
that for a year and then that summer I
actually didn't have the education
courses so I was on an emergency
certificate it was called and I went
back to graduate school and took a
couple of courses in education and
I don't think this is gonna work out for
me hmm and I was pregnant with my first
baby so I had a baby uh and stayed home
for a couple of years okay so that's it
she didn't have the courses and then she
went to try to get the qualification and
she thought this isn't gonna really work
out for me and then she had a baby and
she stayed on for a few years that makes
perfect sense that's very different than
the story she's telling now this is a
problem for her because she already
famously lied about her resume she lied
about being a Native American Indian she
the whitest woman who's ever walked the
face of the earth is she lied in in a
very bad way for her as a leftist and as
a Democrat because racial identity
politics really matters to the left and
so she lied about that bad idea she lied
certainly as early as when she was
teaching at UPenn and then did that help
her get the job at Harvard I don't know
a lot of people seem to think it did
Harvard certainly touted her Native
American ancestry which was not true and
then it turned out it was obviously
alive this dogged her for a little while
and you know this bothered her by the
way because she spent a long time trying
to defend it she took this DNA test and
got her personal prof to the Boston
Globe to run about how she was one
one-thousandth Native American and this
some have indicated her decades and
decades of lying that backfired on her
big-time says she tried to fight it now
she just apologized okay she was just
getting over this now this new scandal
comes out if this new lie hadn't come
out with the Pocahontas thing I've
stopped her from being president I
actually don't think so it's a good hit
it's a very funny hit dogged her for a
long time I don't know that that's
enough
it's been around for a while she made an
egregious mistake she admitted it and
Americans are forgiving people now it
happened again and look we believe in
second chances but do we believe in
third chances or fourth chances as
Americans I don't know about that
because now it's not just a mistake now
it's not just a lie now we've got a
pattern and it's the same kind of lie
you have a privileged woman consistently
lying to make herself look
like a victim you've got her first
pretending to be a victim of race
discrimination then you've got her
pretending to be a victim of sex
discrimination this is not going away
and I think I don't I haven't seen any
actual conservative who's taken her
so-called sex scandal seriously that she
paid off a marine to have sex with him
we should take this one seriously this
is a good hip this is a really good hit
she's just consistently lying about her
racial privilege and her sexual
privilege I'm using the left's terms
because she's gonna have to answer to
the left for those and we should hammer
her for it speaking of sex
discrimination by the way huge story
I'll just give you a little preview of
this one of the biggest Supreme Court
cases possibly ever is coming up
tomorrow and nobody is talking about it
the case is Harris Funeral Homes versus
Equal Employment Opportunity Commission
what this case is about is whether sex
means sex you know male and female man
and woman or whether sex means gender
identity so not your objective sex but
your subjective feelings about your sex
what's the case the case is about this
funeral home owned by a guy named Thomas
Rost for six years at this funeral home
they had an employee name - Anthony
Stevens at the funeral home obviously
it's a very touchy sensitive industry
and so when the people are dealing with
grieving families there's a dress code
Anthony Stevens this employee at the
funeral home agreed to the dress code he
signed a contract saying I will abide by
the dress code six years he abided by
that dress code until one day
Anthony came in and he decided that he
was Amy and so he insisted on wearing a
dress he insisted on wearing a skirt
suit so he's not wearing pants anymore
he's wearing a skirt suit and what
Thomas Ross said is look we like you a
lot Anthony or Amy or whatever you're
going by now but you you can't violate
this dress code you've got grieving
families here and they don't need your
show and your political statement and
your issues to affect them this is about
them it's not about you you agreed to
wear the dress code you got to do the
dress code so
Anthony now Amy leaves and Sue's and so
what happened is the Obama
administration through the Equal
Employment Opportunity Commission sided
with Anthony Stevens now Amy Stevens now
it's the Trump administration Trump's
DOJ supports the funeral home this all
comes down to the Civil Rights Act the
Civil Rights Act bans discrimination on
the basis of sex but Anthony Stevens is
not being discriminated against on the
basis of sex he's being discriminated
against on the basis of his imagination
I mean that's the only argument he's got
for discrimination is that I imagined
myself to be a woman even though I'm not
a woman and therefore I'm being
discriminated against and therefore you
need to sue minyan to let need to let me
wear whatever I want to wear in front of
grieving families even though I signed a
contract saying I wouldn't now the Civil
Rights Act has this has actually already
been interpreted the Civil Rights Act
bans sex discrimination but it does not
require either a sexuality or
androgynous so sexual difference is
still respected everybody in this case
still respects that men there can be
different dress codes for men and women
at the office that the case their court
ruled on this in 1998 so the Obama
administration through this all into
chaos by saying that the word sex maybe
doesn't mean sex you can't have both sex
and gender identity protection the way
to really look at this is it maybe not
even in the employment case but in
sports title 9 sets up says that you
won't discriminate in sports Bay on the
basis of sex so you get women sports
leagues women get to have their own
sports leagues they get to engage in
sports if you now change sexes to mean
gender identity it's not just that
everybody benefits and rights were
expanded to more people you actually
completely undermine the definition of
sex now it's not just that more people
get to play sports it's that women don't
get to play sports you can't have them
both sex is either objective reality or
it's subjective preference and fantasy
and imagination you can't have both at
the same time Ryan Anderson has a great
op-ed on this in the New York Post today
you should go check it out I'm going to
be filling in for Ben's radio show later
we're gonna be talking to the lawyer
who's gonna be arguing this case before
the Supreme Court tomorrow this is a
case to watch a lot depends on this case
it's a about a lot more than pronouns
it's about a lot more than just making
people feel good about themselves this
is about who gets to define reality
itself this is about whether women have
legal protections like in sports leagues
or in bathrooms or their own schools or
anything like that so much depends upon
the pronouns so much depends upon
whether a man at a funeral home is
allowed to wear a dress or not so stay
tuned for that will obviously be
covering it as it comes out we've got a
lot more to get to we got to get to
Kanye West's Sunday services and Kanye
West defending the Republican Party and
Kanye West coming out with a new album
called Jesus's King we have got to get
to the Joker I'm gonna try to get my
thoughts on the Joker if we have time
and then we have from the New York Times
the dumbest article on the Internet
today I love this article it wasn't
usually when I wake up and I say what's
the dumbest article on the Internet
today it kind of takes me a minute no
not today because the New York Times is
publishing an op-ed not about present
political issues but it is what they
call an op-ed from the future the New
York Times is now employing fiction
writers to write actual fiction on the
pages of the New York Times at least
they're honest we'll get to that in a
second but first I gotta say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
end reply man show you got the ben
shapiro show you get them at wall show
you test questions in the mailbag
that'll be coming up on thursday you get
another Kingdom which is out today
another Kingdom season 3 is here it's
the final installment it is absolutely
fantastic I love it
episodes 1 & 2 dropped to day so be able
be sure to go check those out a new
episode is going to drop every single
Monday for the duration if you're a
subscriber though it daily wire you get
really access to them on Fridays so
don't wait subscribe now first two
episodes out today it is it is my
favorite season of it it's getting great
reviews please go check it out another
Kingdom we always talk about how
conservatives need to be in the culture
well here it is the conservatives are
out in the culture and I think it's
great
if this is drew clavin's final
installment if is another Kingdom
trilogy
I am so
real that I get to be a part of it check
it out is gonna be a lot of fun daily
wire calm we'll be right back with a lot
more
okay pastor west is out with his new
Sunday service and his new Christian
album I'm talking about Kanye Priest
Kanye father Kanye how many more titles
can he get he always gives himself all
these titles so I guess I can give them
to him too
Kanye West has been moving toward the
right in recent years politically and
even religiously he's not talking about
atheism and materialism and secularism
and all those religions that are
affiliated with the left wing he's
talking explicitly about traditional
religion specifically about Christianity
and this has been happening for a while
now it's culminating in what he's doing
or Sunday services and Christians and
conservatives are really split on this
some conservatives say we don't want
Kanye's support some Christians say we
hate what Kanye is doing we don't want
him to talk about Jesus how dare you do
it there were good arguments on both
sides but I support yay
I support Kanye I never thought I would
say those words because I'm not a huge
fan of his music I support what he's
doing here so he was doing a Sunday
service to promote his new album Jesus's
King and he did one in Salt Lake City
where he extolled the virtues of the
Republican Party for freeing slaves and
he condemned mental slavery and the
mental slavery of voting for a political
party on the basis of your skin color
here he is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is really terrific to see it is it
is really terrific to see there are a
lot of reasons to be skeptical here one
is for the Christians who don't like
these doing the Sunday service
liturgical abuse is real I would much
rather we all do the like 1962 lat
traditional Latin Mass all the time at
which people would come to that but
that's not exactly the option that we're
being presented with in the culture so
that's real look Kanye West has
exhibited a lot of narcissism in his
career all celebrities do and he's a big
celebrity and also when politics becomes
the center of what celebrities are
talking about it's very annoying that's
not what Kanye is doing here that's not
exactly what Kanye is doing I mean he
comes out there and he says he's got
jesus walks playing in the background
which is one of only two Kanye West
songs that I like Jesus walks and that
he did one with Paul McCartney called
only one which I kind of like - I'm
almost certain Paul McCartney wrote that
song so that maybe that's why I like it
but he's got that song playing which is
pretty good and he says look the
Republican Party freed the slaves and
his point isn't that we all need to vote
for Republicans his point is he says
you're gonna call me a racial slur for
saying that I like Donald Trump I have
my right to an opinion and you don't get
to tell me that I'm gonna have my
opinion he's standing firm on it he came
out a while ago and put the mag a hat on
and hugged Trump and said I love Trump
and people really knocked him for it and
he stood tall he says look I'm not gonna
be a mental slave I'm not going to say
what you forced me to say you mainstream
media you political correctness you I'm
not gonna do that I've got my own
opinions I really like that and I even
sort of like the idea of the Sunday
service you know I yesterday was in
Phoenix and I went to a fabulous Latin
Mass in Phoenix and it was really great
and then afterward we went to have
brunch with a friend of ours and I what
it means is I went to church for
Christians and then I went to church for
modern liberals because brunch is church
for modern liberals they even friends of
mine and put it that way
of course brunches church that's my
Sunday ritual I go out and I have a
mimosa and you know my sacraments are a
mimosa and an egg sandwich that's true
of a lot of people I like brunch and
most of my friends probably are liberal
atheists or liberal materialists or
liberal religious but not spiritual but
not religious I mean they're they're
that kind of thing that's what the
Millennial culture is you've got to meet
people where they are you've got to be
thing all things to all people and
that's a little bit what Kanye is doing
here I think the album is called Jesus's
King the album isn't called Kanye is
king the album isn't called Kanye is
Jesus he's talked a little bit that way
in the past but that doesn't seem to be
the way he's talking now and Connie's
not always talking about his political
views he's just saying that he has the
right to have political views and the
other thing is this is my big defense of
Kanye generally Kanye West has a pretty
good ear I don't like his music that
much but I've always said he has a good
ear so the way I would often put it is
the Kanye West is really good at
listening to good music he has a really
good taste in music and then he raps
over it and ruins it which is not even a
knock on Kanye it's kind of a knock on
hip hop in general but he's got a good
ear for music
so Jesus walks is a good example the
song in Jesus walks is really good walk
with me is a really nice song and then
he does Jesus walks and raps over it and
makes it not as good a sounding song
he's got a good ear for the culture too
he can hear things in the culture that
most people can't hear that's why he's
been on top for a very long time he's
not just following the crowd he's kind
of leading the crowd in the culture and
I think he's hearing that people want
meaning I think that's why he's doing
these Sunday services which is not the
traditional Latin Mass that I go to on
the weekends it's but it's something
it's young people want meaning and
instead of putting that meaning into a
global warming rally which we saw a week
ago he's putting that meaning into a
religious route an explicitly religious
rally an explicitly Christian rally and
he calls the album Jesus as king
people want meaning and if they can as
they're looking for meaning and
everybody
got to serve somebody so they're gonna
find the meeting in global warming or
they're gonna find the meaning in
Christianity and if he's leading people
in that direction I think that's a great
thing if he can bring people around to
Christ I think that's a great thing and
if they can start at Sunday service and
end up at church I think that's a great
thing they're not going to start out at
church they're gonna start out at brunch
and then the question is where they
gonna go after brunch sure they're gonna
go to a political rally for leftism are
they gonna go to a Sunday service
and then once they go to the Sunday
service and they get a little taste I
don't think they're gonna be satisfied
there I think I hope they're gonna want
to start going to church and they're
gonna want to start reading the Bible
and they're going to want to start
experiencing the sacraments they're
gonna want to go to Mass and they're
gonna want a print Cendant religious
experience kanya can bring them there
that's a good thing you know the lyrics
of Jesus walks are pretty good in Jesus
walks
I'm I fear that I'm gonna spawn a
thousand memes by reading this but you
know it is what it is Kanye says God
show me the way because the devil is
trying to break me down
Jesus walks with me the only thing that
I pray is that my feet don't fail me now
I want Jesus Jesus walks and I don't
think there is nothing I can do now to
right my wrongs
Jesus walks with me I want to talk to
God
but I'm afraid because we ain't spoke in
so long I want Jesus it's actually
pretty complex lyrics because what he
says is speaking colloquially he's
saying I don't think there's nothing I
can do now to right my wrongs meaning I
don't think there's anything that I can
do to right my wrongs but what he's
explicitly what he's literally saying is
the Christian message which is I don't
think there is nothing I can do now to
right my wrongs you you can have your
wrongs righted by accepting grace and
this I want Jesus keeps coming through
Jesus walks with me I want to talk to
God but I'm afraid cuz I haven't talked
to him in so long
this is this is true of the guy who goes
to Mass every day this is true of the
guy who's always in the confessional
line like I will stand in the confession
line and you know for those who are
unaware with the our our smells and
bells Catholic rituals we have a
sacrament
of confession where you go and you
confess your sins to a priest and then
the priest conveys the absolution of of
your sins and the forgiveness of your
sins and when I'm standing in that line
I could go every week I could go more
than once a week you still feel the same
society you still feel this gosh I have
to confess then I feel I haven't talked
to God I've been separated from God and
Kanye conveys that and if Kanye is
bringing people around I think it's
great and if Kanye is showing people you
don't need to only have one political
point of view I think that's great and
the enthusiasm with which he does it and
the sort of almost innocence with which
he does it I think is absolutely
terrific I give him a lot of credit if
he lacks in some of the virtues you
can't say that he's not courageous and
courage is a virtue and courage is the
prerequisite for all the other virtues
so I I give him credit I tip my mag
ahead to him before we go I am NOT going
to give a long review of Joker because I
don't want to give spoilers but I really
liked it I don't think it's the greatest
movie ever made I probably won't ever
see it again but I really liked the
movie and you should go see it the fact
that critics are giving it 69 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes and the people are
giving at 90 percent tells you a lot the
movie is very insightful it's not easily
categorized it shows you all
perspectives I think the movie is pretty
anti left I think that it's a political
movie I mean it's about a political
movement it's about an election campaign
so I'm not just reading politics into a
movie where there are none and the
villain is a leftist and the villains or
leftists now one problem here is that
the villain is sort of the protagonist
the Joker is a villain but he's the
protagonist of the film kind of he's
he's still a villain though if you look
at this film with moral clarity
it's very anti leftist I mean the people
who are the clowns who support the Joker
or holding up resist signs the guy was
running for office as a billionaire he's
obviously a trump figure and it exposes
our mental health hypocrisy you know the
same people who say we need to distinct
as mental health
we need to talk about mental health
they're the least likely to do it in the
minute you do it they bite your head off
and it it also gives us a good eye into
free will it doesn't just say oh no
these poor people are destined to misery
their whole lives if you have mental
health issues or if you're poor or if
you're born in a tough family
circumstance you're just destined to
have a tough life it permits free will
in a pretty sophisticated way in a
pretty complex way I think it's it's a
perfect movie for right now for this
moment because one of the songs that
keeps coming up in the previews and it's
in the movie too is send in the clowns
this is a Stephen Sondheim song that is
so misunderstood it's the send in the
clowns where are the clowns and the last
line is they're already here send in the
clowns is people who are wondering what
this song means they've always asked
Stephen Sondheim and sometimes did an
interview he said it's not an esoteric
song the clowns are the ideas that the
clowns are us clown is a word for fool
and it's the song song and a musical
between two people who have variously
loved each other but they've always
screwed it up and the joke is sending
the clowns let's bring a little laughter
into this difficult moment and oh wait
we don't need to send in the clowns
we're the clowns we're the fools we're
the clowns the fact that that song is
being used to market the movie tells you
a lot about this moment we are the
clowns all of us we are the ones we are
the fools we are behaving foolishly and
the vision oblique Neil istic vision
that's presented in the movie is a
vision embraced by a lot of people but
it's a crazy vision it's a dark one it's
one we're living in right now and the
movie takes up the question of comedy
the Joker what is the joke what is
comedy and there's one view of comedy
which is that it's forests it's absurd
it's all about nothing it's all just a
big joke and then there's another vision
of comedy which is like the Divine
Comedy in the Opera Pagliacci Paul
yah-tchi says la comedia you hear la
comedia finita the comedy is finished
and Pope Benedict the 15th apparently
said this on his deathbed he said the
comedy is finished it's not in saying my
life was a big joke a big force
it's him saying life is a comedy it has
a happy ending and Joker explores that
question it allows you
I recommend it maybe next week we'll be
able to talk about more thoughts on this
because I don't I don't want these
spoilers but go see it go see it right
now
so that I can go give you my thoughts on
it before we go I need to talk about the
stupidest article on the Internet today
it's from the New York Times it's called
its 2024 we need to keep abortion legal
in New York thanks to a landmark ruling
that overturned Roe versus Wade abortion
is now illegal everywhere except New
York and Hawaii but a new bill threatens
the legal status of abortions so you'll
notice right away it's not 2024 the
editor has a note this is part of the
op-eds from the future series in which
science fiction authors futurists
philosophers and scientists write op-eds
that they imagine we might read 10 50 or
even 200 years from now so The Times is
admitting that they are now a work of
fiction we already knew that but now
they're admitting it because they can't
they can't complain about what's
happening I mean right now the Trump
presidency is pretty good so they if it
always has to be hypotheticals imaginary
what if fiction so it opens up says the
New York legislature is convening this
week to begin debate on s-97 64 I would
like to offer my thoughts as a
gynecologist who still provides that
rarest of services abortion our legal
status is under threat as our lives have
been for decades more important the
legislators for this passage of this
bill are dishonest in their motives and
willfully blind to the consequences of
it's probable passage so what they don't
understand is Roe vs. Wade they actually
don't know what roe v wade is the op-ed
goes on and it says ever since an a case
in 2022 overturned Roe vs. Wade
14 states have outlawed abortion and
then seven states began prosecuting
women for abortion and now it's illegal
everywhere except pretty much New York
that's if abortion is ly popular people
want abortion then it will be legal in a
lot of places Roe vs. Wade being
overturned won't outlaw abortion it will
just allow states to make their own
decisions as they should because there's
no such thing as a constitutional right
to abortion then goes on they say most
so-called abortion states have adopted
legislation restricting access to
publicly funded abortions legally we
don't currently have publicly funded
abortions so they obviously this New
York Times writer doesn't understand the
law but
well we do have legal or we do have
publicly funded abortions because money
is fungible and we give taxpayer money
to Planned Parenthood and we say it's
only for non abortion services but if
they get the money they're gonna use it
for whatever they do and what they do is
abortion this op Edie
doesn't even know that so they they
don't know that they don't acknowledge
that then they go on they say these laws
disproportionately affect black women we
know this from 70 years ago and it
disproportionately affects black women
would you mean because it allows more
black babies to be born black women are
much more likely to have abortions and
that the abortion proponents push for
this I mean you just heard Bernie
Sanders say we need to go into poor
countries by which he means African
countries and make sure we kill more
babies and this is true in the United
States and the United States more black
babies in New York more black babies are
aborted than are born it just goes on in
this sort of nonsensical way and exposes
the left's opinion of abortion it just
reveals a couple things one they don't
understand the law they don't understand
the Constitution to abortion is a
sacrament to the left it does come down
to abortion the Gorsuch stuff Cantera
I'm sorry the Kavanagh stuff came down
to abortion so much of their political
activism comes down to the right to kill
babies that's what they fear more than
anything that's what they're writing in
the New York Times it is wicked it's
it's illogical and you can see the
illogic of it in the op-ed but it brings
us right back to our first story which
is that girl at the aoc
town hall screaming about how we need to
eat babies everyone said it was so crazy
was so ridiculous it's not it's satire
and satire tells you the truth and we're
seeing that truth which is fiction on
the cover of the New York Times
v leftist paper par excellence the truth
it seems is stranger than fiction and
we're getting a lot of truth out of that
fiction from the left and the truth is
pretty appalling that's our show I'm
Michael Knowles's the Michael Nolt show
when we filling in for Ben's radio show
today so you can listen there otherwise
I'll see you tomorrow
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boy
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis clever
and our technical producer is Austin
Stephens assistant director pavel y
douse key edited by danny D'Amico audio
is mixed by mike core amina hair and
makeup is by joshua alvera and our
production assistant is nick Chien the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
if you prefer facts over feelings if you
aren't offended by the brutal truth if
you can still laugh at the nuttiness
filling our national news cycle well
tune on into the Ben Shapiro show or
you'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
we'll see you there